with acid I smoked weed for a little bit
I didn't really like it so then I went
to cocaine and then graduated to heroin
yeah this is all yeah
and I have a very curious mind so I
wanted to know what it was really like
huh I found out 47 and I mean when you
were 14 13 when you were young girl what
did you what did I dream I thought I was
gonna be at least a nurse or something
like my mother and it just didn't turn
out that way you know there was a lot of
molestation dysfunctional stuff at home
I'm not going to get into that but just
I had I had a very [ __ ] up life yeah
so I ran away from home and I was like
[ __ ] that you're not me
what did you guys write you know and one
thing I always I always I I read it in
the Bible when I was young but I never
really took took it into my heart that
your family will be the first ones to
[ __ ] you over and it's true yeah it's
very true you know your family it [ __ ]
me over when I was a young age sexually
molested me as my mother watched so I
was very very angry and I felt like I
wanted to do something to them so I said
it was best for me to go on yeah yeah
that's all I'm gonna say on that matter
[Music]
so that kind of derail some plans for
life yeah but it's it's never too late
to start over you know me you know and I
I still got a whole life ahead of you
I got a good head I got a very good head
on my shoulders I'm not crazy and I'm
not and I'm not high right now so you
know I mean so you know I could turn it
around
yeah yeah but the key is to get I would
like to thank you for letting me share a
little bit of my world with you uh here
and there just were yep and today we
Jerry Loven by prostituting you know
doing whatever I have to do you know you
can't worry
yeah yeah right you still on it I gotta
get going though babe how do you make
money in the last 24 hours
prostitution
and
how safe you feel doing that I don't
really feel safe but it is what it is
you know I haven't been extremely hurt
ever hurt I've been beat up a little bit
I've been raped a few times but in the
33 years that I've been on the street I
haven't really been hurt you know I've
been at a couple close calls I remember
I got picked up by this guy who I
thought was a security guard he had a
security jacket so it that threw me off
he turned out to be a serial killer and
I was his next big intended victim but
God was with me
because we were [ __ ] the police
followed us over he kidnapped me and
took me to two counties wait yeah and if
it wouldn't have been for the police
putting him under surveillance I'd be
dead right now
yeah it was we were on a Bobby Madison
parking lot you don't darling Madison
right no it's like a
they're like hostess oh yeah yes
that was kind of scary you know he
choked me he choked me I couldn't talk
for two weeks after he had me change
down with a big chain in the front seat
butt naked butt ass naked
okay as he's choking me she doesn't
change yes yes yeah the police have been
looking for him for ten years
Gus yeah Wow
helicopters I heard helicopters at the
last minute I heard helicopters about
you know I looked up that was like my
savior you don't see him I've never been
so happy to see her police in my life
this is a true story
he got 99 years and 99 and a half years
of prison he ain't never coming down
he was white black Hispanic that he was
a Jamaican
I remember his car he had a black cetera
[Music]
he had murdered four prostitutes in
South Central
and here you are still doing it yeah
sometimes you don't get you don't you
don't you don't up you don't suffer
enough you know you don't think
sometimes I think that I don't deserve
to be alive you don't say I don't
deserve to be happy
you know because it's all all that seems
it's my life consists of bad
relationships drugs and selling my body
you know there's no love in my life
you don't know I can't really say that
I've ever been in love because I've
never gave it a chance you don't you so
I always question people's motives you
know
it's amazing how life get derailed that
is anti heartbeat
it could happen so best
and what started it with my mom and dad
got divorced that's what started
everything down universe it was yeah
monster
I was like oh I don't care thing they're
not happy they don't get to be together
but I didn't know that it was gonna
affect me so bad you know I mean deleted
you yeah it did it did so then I was
like okay so now my mom and dad don't
love you no more that's what I that's
what yeah yeah yeah and it was my dad
yeah and during that period I was also
being sexually molested by my dad you
know so here we go again I'm learning
sex sex sex that's all I know
you know so it became my way of life you
know so when I got turned out as a
prostitute it wasn't surprising
and that I was also very good at it
because call of course all my life I'd
be Julian yeah
[Applause]
that's not really a good day because I
woke up with diarrhea throwing up you
know I just
though sir I need to go and get some
[Applause]